hey guys I'm going to answer the
question how to sleep super fast there's
nothing worse than not being able to
sleep at night and being tired the whole
day I had a problem with this so this is
what I found as the reason why people
can't get to to bed fast number one they
have too much light in their room at
night between when it's supposed to get
dark out and by the time they go to bed
at night you're in an environment it's
too light
well guess what guess what triggers the
hormones that help you go to sleep it's
Darkness so you might want to wind down
a little bit sooner and not have so many
bright lights in the room but Darkness
stimulates a hormone called melatonin
which then turns into serotonin those
are hormones that help you sleep now if
you take melatonin that's a bad thing
because you're you're bypassing your
system and you're going to uh be
dependent on it over time or it's going
to interact with your own glands like
the the pineal glance I don't recommend
taking uh melatonin okay but that's one
thing number two TV you watch too much
TV and the news is not good before you
go to bed you don't want to watch scary
movies maybe a comedy best thing to do
is read why because that inflow
sometimes can trigger your body and keep
you up at night too okay number three
can't get to bed because your mind's
racing or you have nervous tension and
it's going going going so what what do
you do if that's the case I recommend uh
kind of correcting the adrenal because
it's a fight of fight situation flight
means adrenal stress there's buildup of
adrenal stress there's two uh simple
remedies that I use one the uh adrenal
KN formula which targets an overactive
adrenal okay you take one before bed and
number two I take adrenal day why
because the adrenal day actually helps
you sleep at night because it targets
the stress that builds up in the body it
helps excessive thinking all night long
and it's a great combination so it'll
help you uh have quietness in your mind
as you go to sleep and then this just
calms the whole body because it really
works on the adrenal flight or fight
stress mode so if that's the situation
go ahead and take take combination I
mean it it's not that expensive and it
really solves a big problem and it's
worth it to have a good night's sleep so
that's what I normally recommend now
number four too much energy let's say
you're an athlete in high school or
college your cells have developed your
energy factories have developed bigger
and bigger and bigger uh mitochondria
they're called and those
mitochondria generate a lot of energy so
people that are athletes have larger
mitochondria so they their capacity for
energy is higher so they generate more
energy and they if they don't exercise
they lay there with all this energy in
the body and they can't sleep that's my
case so what you want to do is you're
going to have to get out there and
exercise every day to get that energy
out and probably not a little thing like
a good 45 minutes of working out or
maybe 40 minutes of working out hard to
get rid of that energy if I don't do
that myself I will lay there with a lot
of excess energy in my body so it's one
of those Catch 22 when when you actually
start it you have to do it continually
you can't stop because the mitochondri
don't shrink back okay so and if it's a
restless leg syndrome that adrenal day
formula will handle it like that and
that's just a it's an adrenal issue that
you have restless legs anything in the
lower part of your body that's more um
Restless or like a nervous energy or
even you climb a flight of stairs and
it's heavier is adrenal okay all right
digestion that's another big one if your
digestion is not working if you're
bloated and you try to go to bed you're
not going to sleep there's a huge
connection between your gut and your
brain it's actually connected by a nerve
called the vagus nerve and so anything
that's goes wrong with the stomach will
actually affect your head and it will
keep you up so you just have to make
sure you definitely do not overeat
especially don't overeat
proteins I mean if you have too much
protein through the day it'll kind of
wire you it's very very triggering like
especially if you have it protein before
a bed the best thing to do is eat
calming things like calcium rich maybe a
little um cheese before a bed that would
be better than other proteins because
that's calcium in it the other thing is
like you don't want to do um um any junk
food because that's going to disrupt and
bloat you as well so if there is a
digestive part there are two simple
things that I do number one is the apple
cider vinegar plus tablet I would take
two to three of these before bed why
because this it's kind of like an
incinerator it just gets your stomach
digesting and then one gallbladder after
you eat why because the gallbladder
helps take the bloating out and so it
really handles the digestive component
to prevention of sleep so if your
problem is digestion handle that if it's
problem adrenal handle that and you will
see that you can sleep a lot better so I
just wanted to cover some key things to
help you sleep because that's really the
most important thing if you're trying to
you know have energy during the day or
feel vital or have a higher mood
elevation sleep is the key all right
I'll see you in the next
video